mehr als 11.000 infizierte an einem tag
ganz deutschland über der magischen 50er
schwelle und der
bundesgesundheitsminister positiv
getestet das virus hat unser land immer
fester im griff
oder soll man besser sagen die angst vor
dem virus denn mit den infektionszahlen
wächst die unsicherheit bei den bürgern
und bei den politiker einig sind sich
die vor allem darin das ganze land nicht
noch einmal ins künstliche koma zu
versetzen
aber wie viele lokale betäubung nötig
sind
das ist völlig offen das oberste gebot
im moment die kontrolle über die
pandemie behalten
ist das noch zu schaffen auch darüber
wollen wir reden mit diesen gästen peter
tschentscher
hamburgs erster bürgermeister warnt wir
sind in einer sehr kritischen phase der
pandemie
christian lindner der fdp-vorsitzende
sagt wir müssen vorsichtig sein aber wir
dürfen die lage nicht überdramatisieren
susanne herold die infektiologen ist
überzeugt wenn sich weiter so viele
menschen anstecken wird auch die zahl
der toten steigt
[Musik]
jagoda marinic die schriftstellerin
stellt fest
der permanente alarm modus treibt die
menschen in den trotz
stefan oschmann der chef des
pharmakonzerns merck ist optimistisch
beim impfstoff werden wir demnächst
entscheidende fortschritte machen und
georg mascolo der investigativ
journalist sagt in der ersten welle
waren wir gut
jetzt wird die nächste viel schwieriger
sein
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner
[Musik]
herzlich liebe zuschauer los geht's die
zahlen steigen die nervosität auch sie
sind die dauer mahner in der korona
krise ihr motto nicht lange fackeln
sondern durchgreifen
bitte bleiben sie wenn immer möglich zu
hause an ihrem wohnort können kontakte
nicht verfolgt werden braucht es am ende
kontakt beschränkungen
das ist dann die vorstufe eines lockdown
mit dem lockdown leid gibt bayern
bundesweit den takt vor
berchtesgaden soll abschrecken wie im
frühjahr als wir aus angst unser
verhalten änderten
doch abschreckungspolitik nutzt sich ab
auch im bundestag wächst der frust über
die methode merkel sünder
es gibt ein bier war und ich habe auch
das gefühl dass es zusammenhänge mit
diesen schalten und diesen kurzfristigen
treffen und deswegen brauchen wir wieder
eine vernünftige debatte und die gehört
in den deutschen bundestag und nicht ins
kanzleramt
das parlament ist die erste gewalt im
staate regierung dürfen nur aufgrund von
gesetzen tätig werden parlamentarisch
verabschiedet worden sind und wir
brauchen auch wieder eine diskussion in
parlamenten damit die menschen
nachvollziehen können welche maßnahmen
sinnvoll nicht sinnvoll sind
für markus söder ist das ein zerreden
der maßnahmen die fdp sollte überlegen
ob der kurs den sie sich der gemeinsam
mit der afg auferlegt wirklich der
richtige fürs land ist das dilemma der
politik soll sie grundrechte heute
wieder einschränken weil vielleicht
übermorgen krankenhäuser überlastet
wären wenn man sich anguckt wie die
spitze der infektionszahlen nach oben
geht
was gibt es hier eigentlich noch zu
diskutieren
fragt michael müller und hier fragen als
erstes den ersten bürgermeister der
stadt hamburg dr changer nicht nach dem
politischen streit sondern nach den
infektionszahlen von heute
wann würden auch sie sagen wir hören auf
zu schnacken hamburg macht dicht wie
berchtesgaden oder geht es gar nicht
nein das geht nicht vielleicht das gaben
ich kenne die bedingungen vor ort nicht
aber hamburg ist eine metropolregion 1,9
millionen hamburg aber eine 5 millionen
metropolregion das lässt sich gar nicht
getrennt
ausschneiden viel wichtiger ist dass wir
in den metropolen in den großen städten
die ja die pandemie letztlich auch
entscheidend dass man in diesem großen
städten sich an die regeln hält die
relativ einfach sind im abstände
einhalten nicht feiern vor allem ich
unter alkoholeinfluss und eben die maske
tragen
insofern ist die sache einerseits sehr
einfach aber natürlich wahnsinnig
kompliziert wenn sie denn in den
metropolen entschieden werden wie sie ja
und wenn es viele sonderregelung gibt wo
wir natürlich auch aufpassen müssen dass
mit unseren maßnahmen wie nicht zu
pauschal sind weil die gerichte sie dann
aufheben wegen unverhältnismäßigkeit wir
müssen auf vieles achten
aber was mir sorge macht sind die zahlen
auch aber vor allem dass es immer noch
einen nennenswerten anteil an menschen
gibt die sagen na das ist doch alles
nicht so schlimm und es gibt immer ein
aber die krankenhäuser sind ja noch
nicht teil aber wir haben ja noch nicht
so hohe totenzahlen ja und außerdem ist
alles so kompliziert also das sind für
mich ein bisschen ausflüchte ich glaube
alle müssten jetzt verstehen das ist
ernst und es nützt nichts immer
schärfere regeln zu machen wenn schon
die alten nicht eingehalten werden wir
brauchen jetzt disziplin und dazu gehört
aber allerdings auch kontrolle und
sanktionen und deswegen ist unsere
polizei sehr aktiv die einhaltung der
regeln auch an turnieren ja und jetzt
ist nicht nur regeln gibt sondern ganz
genau
die also operiert beispiel ist wir haben
am letzten wochenende nach der
sperrstunde in einer im keller eines
klubs über 90 menschen aus dem aus dem
kellerraum aus dem feiern sozusagen
herausholen müssen als polizei das ist
etwas was wirklich sehr
verantwortungslos
neben ihnen sitzt jagoda marinic
geschätzte publizistin schriftstellerin
sie haben
in der anfangsphase von corona 1 corinna
tagebuch geschrieben und verfolgen
natürlich auch die
gesellschaftspolitische diskussion von
marina viele kleine ausgangssperren und
ausnahmetatbestände fühlen sich
irgendwann wieder an wie ein großer
ausnahmezustand ja also ich bin wenn ich
ihnen zuhöre höre ich genau das was mir
so ein bisschen sorge bereitet wenn es
in dieser ansprache noch mal 18 monate
gehen soll weil ich glaube bei allem
respekt dass das nicht funktionieren
wird also ich glaube nicht dass wir
immer sagen können schaut euch mal an so
wie herr müller da sitzt daher gibt es
keine widerrede also wir leben in einer
demokratie und es muss auch widerrede
geben und es sollte wieder rede geben
wir glaub ich glaube wir müssen einfach
verstehen und das ist jetzt für mich so
anders als als ich dieses tagebuch
schrieb da war ich auch in dieser
schockstarre
wir wussten nicht wir kannten nicht man
musste sozusagen so prophylaktisch wie
möglich verhindern was gegen und darin
war deutschland sehr erfolgreich jetzt
in der zweiten welle auf die wir ja
sozusagen zu gehen und in der wir schon
sind geht es glaube ich darum zu
verstehen diese krise wird ein gewisser
normalzustand also für mich geht es im
moment darum zu akzeptieren wir haben es
nicht geschafft das einzudämmen
und wie schaffe ich es eigentlich die
bevölkerung mitzunehmen und zu einer art
krisen-management zu sagen wir haben
dieses virus wir haben regeln die helfen
wir müssen vielleicht noch besser auf
die wissenschaftler hören ich habe heute
den podcast gehört vom ndr
da sind tipps die wir noch lange nicht
befolgt haben zum beispiel die
nachverfolgung dieser quellen also nicht
nur nach vorne zur cluster genau quält
cluster nicht nur nach vorne suchen
sondern auch nach hinten zu gucken wo
ist eigentlich die quelle der mensch
oder der ort der die anderen infiziert
das haben wir so noch nicht umgesetzt
das heißt ich lebe ein bisschen mit
dieser theorie aus dem krisen management
da gibt es so eine these die sagt es ist
keine krise egal ob beim hurricane oder
jetzt eine pandemie 10 80 10 10 prozent
verstehen die krise und die manager die
krise dazu gehören sie oder wer auch
immer 80 prozent orientieren sich nach
den zehn prozent die sie verstehen und
zehn prozent gehen einfach nicht mit
beim hurricane sind es ungefähr die die
halt dann liegen bleiben und sagen ich
sehe doch kein winter kommt kein harry
caine und die fahren auch im
schlechtesten aber so eine krise die
kann man auch meistern mit diesen zehn
prozent verweigern
und ich glaube es ist wichtig dass wir
uns in der ansprache mehr fokussieren
auf wie
lebe ich regeln vor die die 80 prozent
mitmachen und das zeigen ja auch jede
umfrage zeigt 80 prozent der deutschen
bevölkerung gehen damit einfach durch
positive ansprache aber die zu
verbessern was genau können wir tun wie
genau können wir helfen dieses tagebuch
des drosten zum beispiel empfiehlt
kontakt tagebücher um zu wissen wo war
vielleicht so ein quell infektions ort
also für mich wäre sozusagen die tonlage
jetzt zu verschieben wichtig und es war
ja auch schon angesprochen worden
das parlament ins spiel zurückzubringen
also ich kann eine krisensituation
ausrufen für sechs wochen für acht
wochen
aber wenn es jetzt schon heißt wir
wissen nicht mal ob die impfungen
wirklich ein ende dieser
ausnahmezustände was abstand und so
weiter heißen wird dann möchte ich dass
eine krise mit einem parlament
gemeistert wird und wir da wirklich
breit diskutieren und es nicht gesagt
wird da gibt es keine widerrede da gibt
es ganz viel rede und widerrede zu
leisten glaube ich kommen wir vielleicht
noch mal zu den maßnahmen die jetzt erst
mal gut getroffen werden müssen ich
möchte dazu begrüßen in frankfurt die
infektiologen susanne herold einen
schönen guten abend zu ihnen frau herold
wir sind bei einem politischen versuchen
nämlich dem sogenannten beherbergungs
verbot gedanklich noch mal ganz kurz da
hat die politik versucht das virus
auszusperren das war nicht besonders
clever wie wir jetzt alle wissen kann
man das virus einsperren
ja das ist schwierig also mit dem
beherbergungs verbot war ja auch
verbunden dass das an vielen in vielen
verschiedenen bundesländern
unterschiedlich gehalten gehandelt wurde
und das hat natürlich zur folge dass die
akzeptanz in der bevölkerung relativ
schwierig ist
keiner versteht mehr warum hier und
warum da nicht außerdem ist die dynamik
sehr stark der infektions ausbreitung
das heißt wir haben ständig neue
situationen neue kreise mit über 50 pro
100000 inzidenz und das ist einfach
schwierig können wir das virus
einsperren
wir können verhindern dass wir das es
sich weiter ausbreitet denn es braucht
ja eine wird es braucht uns das kann
nicht alleine das braucht jemanden den
es infiziert und wir geben es weiter und
insofern es ist sowas oder videos die
ganze zeit schon sagen dass wir einfach
jetzt jeder für sich selbst an die hna
denken muss und für sich entscheiden
muss wo muss ich unbedingt hin wo kann
ich mich vielleicht zurücknehmen muss
eine feier eben nicht stattfinden jetzt
und so weiter und so weiter also die
verantwortung des einzelnen ist ganz
klar gefragt und dann kommt es zu so
einer situation nicht kann das virus
einsperren oder seine ausbreitung
verhindern als einzelne bürger die sind
bei christian lindner vorsitzender der
fdp sie schauen mit mir gemeinsam noch
mal auf die lage des landes wenn
deutschland über kurz oder lang ein
risikogebiet würde ein hochrisiko gebiet
würde sagt die fdp dann dann helfen uns
immer noch diese lokalen aus sperr
ausgangsverbot ich will es umgekehrt
sagen frau illner ein zweiter lockdown
in deutschland muss ausgeschlossen
werden
und jede krisenstrategie muss sich daran
orientieren dass wir das komplette
runterfahren unseres landes ausschließen
weil die sozialen folgen von menschen
die die in der einzimmerwohnung als
singles vereinsamen menschen die in
altenpflegeeinrichtungen ihre verwandten
nicht mehr sehen konnten kinder und
jugendliche die das recht auf bildung
nicht verwirklichen konnten die
millionen menschen die sorge haben um
ihre wirtschaftliche existenz das ist
auch ein risikofaktor und den müssen wir
mit berücksichtigen jetzt geht es darum
dass wir kluge maßnahmen finden die in
ganz ihrer meinung die wir auch über
einen längeren zeitraum nötigen falls
durchhalten können
dazu gehören die hier gehen und
abstandsregel und dazu gehört dass wir
in den blick nehmen wo die wirklichen
risiken sind und die risiken gehen doch
aus von massenveranstaltungen von
besäufnissen ich sage das auf deutsch in
der partyszene von berlin illegalen club
veranstaltungen und anderes mehr
große hochzeiten das muss unterbunden
werden damit auf der anderen seite
soziales und wirtschaftliches leben und
wenn möglich ist und damit sind wir bei
georg mascolo investigativer journalist
hat sich lange und ausgiebig befasst mit
pandemieplänen der whu auch das rk ii
und schaut sich in den letzten
wochen gemeinsam mit seiner frau auch
regierungshandeln an in diesem land seit
märz seit beginn dieser pandemie
befürchten sie eher mascolo das
berchtesgaden morgen überall ist ich
hoffe jedenfalls dass es nicht so kommt
war ja christian lindner völlig recht
hat im zweiten lok können wir uns nicht
leisten und gleichzeitig erleben wir uns
drum herum dass länder die es sich noch
viel weniger leisten können einen
solchen locker und zu verhängen ist
trotzdem tun
ich glaube in dieser zweiten phase wird
es jetzt schwer wenn wir einmal
zurückblicken dann ist es ja so dass ein
großer teil der welt mit respekt manche
auch mit bewunderung darauf schauen wie
wir das in der ersten runde hinbekommen
haben
und während es viele staaten gegeben hat
die sich in der ersten runde nicht nur
deutschland ganz gut geschlagen haben
kann man sehen dass es ihn in der
zweiten runde dann sehr schlecht
gegangen ist israel österreich
tschechien in denen grunde die
diskussion um das masken tragen
begonnen hat das heißt wir kämpfen jetzt
im grunde in der zweiten runde darum
dass wir die geschlossenheit zwischen
politik und gesellschaft die uns in der
ersten runde dann doch so gut dadurch
getragen hat wie wir die erhalten können
an manchen stellen würde ich sagen
zurückerobern können und das wird
schwieriger werden weil die
weltgesundheitsorganisation auf ein
phänomen hinweis dass nicht ganz neu ist
aber dass wir jetzt alle einmal am
eigenen leibe erleben nämlich dass der
so genannten pandemischen erschöpfung
man ist es im grunde leid wir haben ja
alle darauf gehofft es im grunde mit dem
sommer das schlimmste dann doch vorbei
sein würde
viele haben ich glaube ziemlich
verwundert auf die kanzlerin geschaut
als diesen september von 19.200
infektionen gesprochen hat und nun
erleben wir heute eine zahl die davon
jedenfalls nicht mehr so weit entfernt
ist
also ich glaube und ich hoffe dass wir
auch heute abend darüber reden die frage
wie wir den konsens der uns im frühjahr
so gut gedient hat wie wir den
wiederherstellen können um durch die
schwierigen monate zukommen die vor uns
liegen ist glaube ich das entscheidende
war nochmal jedenfalls in den nächsten
monaten wird uns ein sommer nicht retten
warum das so schwierig wollt ihr
beispiel von dem hurrikan ist ja sehr
sehr anschaulich aber wir haben eine
besonderheit die zehn prozent die in
arica ignorieren und sagen ich kümmere
mich nicht bringen sich selber in gefahr
und kann selbst zu schaden
die anderen 90 prozent die sich
zurückgezogen die sich gerettet haben
sind dadurch nicht beeinträchtigt und in
unserer situation in der pandemie die
zehn prozent die sich nicht an die
regeln halten wie das ignorieren die
gefährten das gesamte projekt also alle
und das ist der unterschied wir können
nicht einfach hinnehmen dass diese zehn
prozent von denen sie sprechen sagen ist
mir doch egal ich mache die partys
weiter und das kümmert mich nicht weil
sich das finde ich genau nicht also wenn
man diesen er sich höher wirklich gerne
diese podcast an unter drosten spricht
immer wieder von vernachlässigbaren
infektionen also auch so eine pandemie
verträgt ich meine das weiß ich ja frau
harry oder salzig aber soweit ich
informiert bin verträgt auch die gewisse
infektionen nur man muss verhindern dass
diese krankheit oder diese
infektionsgeschehen sozusagen in
clustern geschehen kann ich glaube schon
dass wir mit einer gewissen kritischen
menge herr droste sagt ja auch so zu
sagen wenn wir jetzt schon die kontakte
suchen ist die person eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so gefährlich vielleicht
steckt die nur noch 2 3 an
also auch diese regel die frau merkel so
schon erklärt hat eine person steckt
zwei oder drei oder vier die stimmt
eigentlich bedingten es gibt ja noch ein
faktor 20 80 also 20 prozent sind super
spacer und die stecken ganz viele an
während die anderen 80 sehr wenige
anstecken also das ist eine viel
differenziertere krankheit als solche
erklärungen und ansprachen also nicht an
schalt nicht als krankheit sondern
infektionsgeschehen und verbreitung und
ich fans eben da so wichtig die
expertise von den virologen noch stärker
in die öffentlichkeit so und also was
ist wirklich gefährlich dann das wissen
noch mal besser vielleicht mit einer
kommunikations psychologen oder
verhaltenspsychologie zu überdenken wie
bringen wir die bevölkerung dazu so wie
herr mascolo sagte ein verhalten
gemeinsam einzuüben und wieder so ein
geist zu kriegen von natürlich schaffen
wir das gemeinsam wenn wir dieses
solidarische denken zurückerobern
es gibt auch gute nachrichten das virus
als wir den lockdown den erdmännchen
streiten option lockdown war aber locker
und heißt im englischen rest
aktionen und die hatten wir mit etwas
geringeren gerade als andere länder
die frage ist es gibt entwarnungen also
man weiß jetzt wirklich die menschen bis
60 haben in der regel nicht so schwere
vor schweren ja und das war müssen wir
damals nicht so also damit können hier
arbeiten und ich glaube wir sind viel
kompetenter und müssen lernen viel
differenzierter zu streiten als zu sagen
diese zehn prozent die würden bei so
einer pandemie alles kaputt machen
dadurch entsteht für mich auch diese
stimmung der permanenten hetze
aufeinander wurde jeder sagt er trägt
die maske nicht und der vermutlich
würden wir auch in gewissen prozentsatz
verweigerer gut durch die krise kommen
wenn der rest nämlich diese 80 prozent
die sagen ja ich gehe mit und ich
erinnere mich zurück an diese
erfolgreiche erste phase und ich lerne
gemeinsam um aber wir brauchen anreize
was wir lernen müssen sogar aktiver
gehabt wir haben hunderte an das sind
ausgegeben
aber das ist das wesen das sich auch
nicht daran glaube dass sich prävention
im kern mit repression durchsetzen lässt
deswegen bin ich wenn ich heute die
meldung lese am wochenende wird es in
berlin zu einem großen einsatz kommen
und die bundespolizei kommt auch noch
dazu gebe ich zu dass ich hin und
hergerissen wenn ich glaube dass
persönlich dass die beiden wichtigsten
ressourcen die ein land hat um gut durch
eine pandemie zu kommen ein gutes
gesundheitssystem ist und das vertrauen
der menschen in das handeln der
politiker die sie durch diese krise
führen und hoffentlich aus ihr heraus
führen deswegen verträgt glaube ich ein
system das 10 15 20 prozent der menschen
die sagen würden ich halte mich nicht an
die regeln glaube ich dass es unmöglich
werden wird ist mit polizei
durchzusetzen und ich glaube dass der
ansatz sein muss dass so viele wie
möglich sich freiwillig und aus
überzeugung an die regeln halten und das
dann allerdings der einsatz staatlicher
mittel das glaube ich auch notwendig ist
für diejenigen die es überhaupt nicht
wollen und überhaupt nicht begreifen
wollen weil es sonst auf der anderen
seite auch schwer wird denjenigen die
sich an die regeln halten wollen zu
erklären wenn sie die bilder von
denjenigen sehen
die sich sanktionsfrei nicht daran
halten also diesen diesen weg zu finden
nicht so sehr auf staatliche machtmittel
und doch mehr auf überzeugung zu setzen
diese balance zu finden
das wird glaube ich in den nächsten
monaten eine schwierige aufgabe ich
glaube dass die die rückdatierung auf
die erste phase uns jetzt im herbst und
winter auch nur bedingt helfen wird wir
sind weiter gott sei dank man hört von
medizinern die behandlungsmethoden sind
auch fortgeschrittene im vergleich zu
dem was man im frühjahr sah die
orientierung nur an der zahl der
neuinfektionen ist aus meiner sicht auch
nie ausreichend um die lage zu
beschreiben
die zahl der neuinfektionen in einem
landkreis steigt stark an wenn es viele
fälle zum beispiel in einem
fleischverarbeitenden betrieb gibt dass
man sehr genau unterscheiden situationen
öffentlicher gesundheitsdienst die man
übrigens noch verstärken kann
die auslastung in den krankenhäusern und
andere träger also insofern das sind die
parameter und ich glaube dass wir seit
über drei dinge nachdenken sondern das
erste ist dass wir die menschen die
besonders schutzbedürftig sind auch
besonders schützen denkt noch mal an
meine eigene großmutter mit 90 dies
besonders schutzbedürftig wir brauchen
hier konzepte die sicherstellen dass
diese menschen nicht mit dem virus in
kontakt kommen und zugleich nicht
vereinsamt sehr voraussetzung voll da
geht es um test strategien für die
menschen in pflegenden berufen sehr
voraussetzung es folgt das zweite ist
ich glaube es gibt ganz großen bereich
der selbstverantwortung wo wir
entscheiden müssen individuell setzen
wir uns dem risiko aus dass wir zwar
jetzt hier so nebeneinander sitzen ein
meter fünfzig jahre daraus gemessen dass
ich ein meter fünfzig es wird ein
restrisiko bleiben und wir als
erwachsene entscheiden weil er
vielleicht keine gesundheitliche
vorerkrankung kamen begehen dieses
restrisiko 1
und ich muss ihnen sagen ich habe volles
verständnis dafür mit jemand sagt ich
ziehe mich aus dem öffentlichen leben
zurück weil ich möchte dieses risiko für
mich nicht eingehen und dieses
verständnis müssen wir aufbringen zum
beispiel als arbeitgeber wenn menschen
sich in das home office jetzt
zurückziehen wollen und es gibt den
dritten punkt ich kann das auch herrn
tschentscher nicht ersparen
die qualität der politischen
entscheidungen muss besser werden
ich dachte es wären damit an hellen
ja aber nicht so einfach mal und wir
tragen ja in ländern auch verantwortung
sind ja auch in regierungsverantwortung
in drei ländern deshalb richtet sich das
an die staatliche
verantwortungsgemeinschaft insgesamt und
jetzt nicht an einen spd politiker
sondern an uns gerade ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass eine solche
fehleinschätzung wie das beherbergungs
verbot niemals beschlossen worden wäre
wenn das vorher im parlamentarischen
verfahren diskutiert worden wäre da
wären nämlich die frage gestellt worden
in der debatte bringt das was sind es
wirklich die dienstreisen und die
familienurlaube der der vierköpfigen
familie aus berlin mit zwei kleinen
kindern die maske tragen und die in
mecklenburg vorpommern auf dem land oder
am bodensee familienurlaub machen ist
das ein super spreading event und dass
wir im parlamentarischen verfahren als
unverhältnismässig zurückgewiesen worden
und gerade solche offensichtlichen
fehlentscheidungen die von gerichten
kassiert werden untergraben das
vertrauen zum beispiel der 80 prozent
die sie genannt haben und deshalb gehen
die zahlen die zustimmungswerte ja
bedauerlicherweise zurück empfehlung
also ist wieder stärker im
parlamentarischen romantisierend
empfunden worden und damit ist der ball
bei hans schenker wir fangen von hinten
an erste frage nach den gerichten
gerichte haben den politikern auf die
sprünge geholfen weil sie sich
offensichtlich nicht mehr genug mühe mit
dem begründen gegeben haben hätten also
ich kann ja nur für hamburg sprechen wir
haben die
verwaltungsgerichtsentscheidung
eigentlich so erlebt dass unsere regeln
bestätigt wurden selbst das
beherbergungs verbot ist in hamburg noch
mal bestätigt worden vor kurzem wir
haben jetzt unsere sperrstunden regelung
bestätigt bekommen vor dem
verwaltungsgericht wir haben damals
diese gesteuerten einzelhandels
beschränkungen vom
oberverwaltungsgericht bestätigt
bekommen die gerichte verstehen schon
dass die politik auch an einer in einer
unklaren lage herzt und auch schnell
entscheiden muss
das wird auch juristisch anerkannt ich
finde aber dass diese dinge sich jetzt
gar nicht widersprechen man kann nicht
dass eine machen und das andere lassen
ich finde diese diese überlegung wie wir
noch besser kommunizieren ich meine wir
kommunizieren mittlerweile auf allen
kanälen
wir machen livestreams aus unseren
pressekonferenzen erklären und bringen
und akzeptanz ich sehe aber dass diese
zehn prozent die anderen frustrieren ich
sage ihnen mal ein beispiel der tim
mälzer der in hamburg ein bekannter ein
ambitioniertes enormes ja ja ja
besonders ärgert er hat sich richtig
erzürnt darüber dass andere gastronomen
und zwar wenige so tun als wären sie das
nichts angeht und das ist das problem
das man ja auch die akzeptanz der acht
genau diese stimmung will ich nicht und
ich würde diesen auftritt statt
ich sage mir das ist das was ich
beobachte dass leute die sagen ich ist
es für mich auch nicht leicht und dann
möchte ich immer sehr gerne dass die
anderen mitziehen und dieses element das
müssen wir schon beachten so kommen sie
lässt bevor vorjahr bruder noch eine in
der retouren nochmals auf ein argument
von christian lindner
wenn man viel zustimmung hat und wir
haben noch verhältnismäßig viel
zustimmung der menschen in diesem land
zu politischem handeln kann man dann auf
parlamentsdebatten verzichten kann man
auf das fußballherz ich meine der
bundestags an vielen entscheidungen
beteiligt waren sie haben viele dieser
gesetze mit beschlossen die jetzt im
rahmen dieser corona pandemie gefasst
wurden wir haben in hamburg eine
ständige erörterung in unseren
parlamentarischen ausschüssen in der im
parlament in der bürgerschaft gibt es
aktuelle stunde nicht erhalt der
regierungserklärung es ist ein
diskussionsprozess
aber in solchen phasen muss man sehr oft
und da sind wir nicht nur berechtigt
sondern wir sind auch moralisch und von
der verantwortung verpflichtet
konsequent zu handeln und zwar auch in
so kurzen zeitabständen oft dass man das
nicht in parlamentarische normale
beratung einbauen kann
und jetzt nostradamus möchte ich ja als
überzeugter parlamentarier widersprechen
der deutsche bundestag hat auch
komplizierteste gesetzgebung in der
pandemie im rekordtempo realisiert dass
wir auch immer möglich und wissen sie
ich habe den eindruck dass in dieser
besonderen situation sich regierung und
verwaltung auch gar nicht mehr gerne auf
das parlament abstützt ich mache das in
einem punkt deutlich nach den bund
länder konferenzen die es in der ersten
phase der pandemie gegeben hat gab es
danach mindestens informell immer eine
beteiligung des deutschen bundestages
weil die bundeskanzlerin die
parlamentsfraktion also
vorsitzenden in einer telefonschalte
unterrichtet hat noch nicht einmal mehr
das findet statt der deutsche bundestag
wird über die medien und über podcasts
informiert und das geht aus einem grund
nicht wenn man im parlament über die
krisenstrategie und maßnahmen debattiert
selbst wenn eine regierungsmehrheit sich
anders entscheiden würde können die
vorhandenen kritiker und skeptiker in
der gesellschaft zumindest sicher sein
dass ihr argument im parlament in der
öffentlichkeit genannt und abgewogen
worden ist und ich glaube dass auch
diese öffentliche auseinandersetzung
über eine krisenstrategie zur wie soll
ich sagen selbst versöhnung der
gesellschaft mit sich enorm beiträgt
weil so haben viele das gefühl dass ihre
persönlichen wirtschaftlichen sorgen
ihre skepsis gegenüber maßnahmen und
artikuliert bleiben das wird wage
gesprochen über unheil mit regierungen
die dann konsequent sagen sie
durchgreifen der tschentscher sie sind
ein vornehmer man andere
regierungssprecher chefs sprechen davon
eher sollten die zügel angezogen werden
was ist das allein für ein vokabular
gegenüber dem souveränen den bürgerinnen
und bürgern das zügel angezogen werden
sollen die menschen in deutschland sind
grundrechtsträger um es mal juristisch
auszudrücken
da muss sich der staat rechtfertigen
wenn ein freiheiten ein greift hier
fragen gleich noch nach der
selbstverantwortung dazu kommen wir noch
weil diese selbstverantwortung ja nicht
nur sich selbst sondern eben auch andere
betrifft aber die frage an den
journalisten die kritik
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist die
letzte und die davor sind kein
verfassungsorgan sagt auch die fdp warum
sind sie dennoch in der jüngsten zeit zu
den wichtigsten entscheidungsträgern
geworden weil wir natürlich beim
infektionsschutzgesetz eine sehr
komplizierte lage haben die kanzlerin
sitzt mit am tisch obwohl sie von vielen
in der welt als mächtigste frau der welt
tituliert wird aber wenn es um fragen
des infektionsschutz geht tatsächlich
ziemlich machtlos ist deswegen ist wenn
man so will dieses gremium zusammen
kommen ich finde dass sie völlig recht
haben es wird eine sache geben egal wie
sich infektionszahlen erlebt in diesem
land entwickeln werden die dieses virus
irgendwie zum stillstand bringen kann
und das ist die politische debatte über
die frage welche maßnahmen angemessen
sind und welche es eben nicht sind
ich würde auch wenn es ein thema der
vergangenen woche ist gern noch einmal
zum beherbergungs verbot zurückspringen
und zu der frage der qualität politische
entscheidung weil ich fürchte dass es
beim beherbergungs verbot in wahrheit
noch ein ganz kleines bisschen schlimmer
ist als es bisher im schienen aber ich
will vorweg schicken dass ich großen
respekt habe wenn man das ganze nun seit
februar märz folgt das ich gesehen habe
wie sehr diejenigen die zu entscheiden
haben auch mit sich ringen unter welchem
druck unter welchen unsicherheiten
entscheidungen getroffen werden
das beherbergungs verbot gehört aber
leider nicht dazu sondern ich glaube
dass da der konflikt die katastrophe
sich geradezu abgezeichnet hatte dass in
wahrheit schon am 6 mai als die
kanzlerin und die ministerpräsidenten
die sogenannte notbremse entschieden
haben ist also haushaltsabfälle das
schlimmste hinter uns haben und um einen
lock down nun im ganzen land zu
verhindern hat man sich darauf geeinigt
hat gesagt wenn wir irgendwo diese
berühmten 50 infektion auf sieben tage
auf 100000 einwohner haben und keine
besserung in sicht ist
dann kommt es zu einer art regional
lockte und die verabredung ist damals
gewesen dass diejenigen die diese
situation bei sich haben
dafür sorgen müssen dass ein und
ausreisen aus diesen gebieten möglichst
unterbunden werden
es ist ein alter entscheidung eine alte
entscheidung in dieser runde schon am 6
mai so kenne ich es haben leute wie ihr
tschentscher wenn es anders war kann das
jetzt auch gern sagen darauf hingewiesen
dass das nach allem was man weiß keine
praktikable regelung sein
und so ist das ganze im grunde den
ganzen sommer über diskutiert worden wir
haben dann gütersloh und warendorf
gehabt das sind die ersten beherbergungs
verbote gewesen aber im grunde hat man
gewusst dass man sich auf ein
instrumentarium geeinigt hat das in dem
moment wenn es wirklich ernst werden
würde wenn der metropolregion betroffen
sein würde dass das dann letztlich gar
nicht tragen sind diejenigen die
eigentlich dafür hätten sorgen müssen
dass nicht gereist wird haben gar nicht
dafür sorgen können dass nicht gereist
wird so dass andere länder gesagt haben
naja dann treffen wir über uns
vorkehrungen dafür dass sie nicht kommen
das heißt hier ist ein konflikt der
zugegeben auch sehr schwierig ist nie
aufgelöst worden und ich glaube wir sind
im grunde sehenden auges dann am ende in
diesen krach hat das ganze in diesem
krach geendet und man muss leider sagen
dass er ich glaube bei den menschen viel
glaubwürdigkeit gekommen ein aspekt kurz
ergänzt haben wir reden jetzt über eine
ist eine nebensache die meisten ländern
in den meisten ländern mit langer
aufgehoben ist was ich die träger augen
entscheidungen und jetzt schon es geht
um den beschluss den es schon gibt dass
wir versuchen den innerdeutschen
reiseverkehr noch einmal sorgfältig zu
betrachten zu ja einfach zu reflektieren
was in den herbst wenn ich bin ja ihrer
meinung ich gehörte zu denen die gesagt
haben
das funktioniert nicht in einer in einer
metropole das ist nicht ja es waren
nicht viele die das so gesehen haben
aber ich habe das damals diesen
eingelegt hatte so gesehen ja und das
ist jetzt so dass wir über diesen einen
punkt treten der der eine kleine wirkung
hat aber nicht funktioniert er macht
eigentlich mehr ärger als als er uns
einbringen deswegen brauchen wir eine
neue regelung im verfahren der verfahren
her ist die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
hier nicht entdeckt werden wollen wir
die bundestag aushebeln wollten oder
weil wir fanden es braucht jetzt ein
neues gremium sind es gab ein riesen
bedürfnis nach koordination einer der
hauptvorwürfe ist ja nicht das parlament
und regierung nicht miteinander
austauschen sondern das ist so und so
vielfältig scheint man die
ministerpräsidenten-konferenz hatte
immer den anspruch zu überlegen wie
können wir uns vereinheitlichen können
wir alles berücksichtigen was ist ein
problem gibt in unterschiedlichen
ländern sind die lagen ja
unterschiedlich und es war immer der
versuch können wir einen gemeinsamen
nenner ein gemeinsames signal und auch
gemeinsame standards entwickeln und das
ist ein großes bedürfnis das höre ich
immer wieder dass leute sagen
warum ist es hier so und bei uns anders
und bei dem wieder an diese
einheitlichkeit kann doch vom parlament
ausgehen also ich verstehe da überhaupt
keinen widerspruch im gegenteil ich fand
diesen effekt dass sie beherbergungs
verbot war er das erste kurz darauf
sperrstunde und da war für mich wiederum
dieses thema ansprache zwei große ideen
dieser dieser dieser eben dieses
gremiums wurden quasi über nacht gekippt
und damit hatten ja die gegner plötzlich
recht und dann kommt so eine situation
sozusagen dieses regierende gremium im
moment dass die pandemie steuert und die
leute die sagen nicht lass mir mein
laden nicht schließen
und ich finde auch umgekehrt genau
diesen zungenschlag so ja die
gastronomen gehören dann nicht zu ich
meine das sind leute deren existenzen
dieses jahr massiv gefährdet worden sind
das heißt die gucken auch jeder wie
überlebe ich damit und vielleicht können
wir da auch in der ansprache allen
gerade zurückdrehen und gemeinsam
nachdenken wie schaffen wir es dass die
gastronomie überlebt wie schaffen wir es
dass jugendliche feiern können wenn
dessen humanes bedürfnis ist gibt es
pandemie fähiges feiern